Richie aiel was the brother of Jackie
aiel who was head of the Deo crime
family when the series started Richie
was in prison for 10 years when all this
was happening so when he reemerged
things were much different than he
remembered he resented Tony as the boss
another complicating Factor was that
Richie started dating his old flame
Janice soprano Tony's older sister the
scheming and power hungry Janice would
needle Richie about Tony urging him to
make a move to take over the family but
what looked like it would become a
deadly power struggle between rich and
Tony had a shocking ending after Richie
and Janice got engaged they got in an
argument as Janice defended Richie's
gayson Little Ricky Richie nonchalantly
punched her in the face and then started
eating dinner Janice responded as such
I'm in no move for
you Tony cleaned up after her and put
her on a bus out of town as two of his
biggest headaches canceled each other
out Richie died in the season 2 episode
the night in white satin armor